[Musique]
pour éviter tout contact nous proposons
un choix très choix de l'animal en
quelque sorte sur le site que le
questionnaire de de l'environnement
familial soit roupies également sur le
net
l'envoi d'une pièce d'identité puis
déplacement dont le refuge où les
salariés les bénévoles restent à une
dizaine de mètres de la personne que
l'on met seul à l'extérieur des
bâtiments avec l'animal si le fit ce
fait la suite de la procédure est la
même si ce n'est qu'on régularise
régularise pardon après l'ensemble de la
procédure qui n'est plus à ce moment-là
que purement administrative c'est ce
qu'on appelle un attendant celui vers un
pardon une adoption solidaire pour
lutter contre l'abandon excusez moi
c'est à dire que l'animal qui est pris
en adoption par la personne sauf deux
animaux celui avec lequel elle part mais
aussi celui qu'on va pouvoir récupérer
dans une fourrière et qui aurait été
irrémédiablement quand danic
[Musique]
le questionnaire est assez précis il est
assez long ont pu éventuellement avoir
un contact par téléphone ensuite si on a
besoin de renseignements complémentaires
je pense que si la personne
la vraie envie de prendre un animal et
qu'ensuite elle est conseillée par les
agents qui sont des professionnels de la
relation homme animal il n'y a pas de
raison que ça se passe mal nous avons
honte sur l'année moins de quatre bourgs
sont de retour de gens qui viennent
on a donné 43 mille animaux à l'adoption
l'an dernier d'un chiffre considérable
on a moins de 4% des gens qui reviennent
parce que finalement ils ont un souci
avec l'animent
[Musique]
on a eu vraiment peur il ya des
imbéciles qui sont amusés à diffuser
cette techno sur sur le net
il n'y a pas de communication du virus
par l'animal
on sait les gens ont réagi
intelligemment et avec prudence
on a toujours j'allais dire le même
nombre d'abandons que d'habitude mais il
n'y a pas eu d'augmentation sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour les 55
refuges dont les trois que nous avons
dans 78 nous sommes presque à saturation
c'est à dire que nous avons 90 %
d'occupation
sachant que nous devons garder une
petite marge de sécurité pour le cas ça
c'est produire en bretagne en début de
semaine dernière pour le cas où tous nos
salariés seraient malades en même temps
ce qui nous obligerait à évacuer nous à
niveau sur d'autres refusent